wir schalten zu unserem kollegen philipp
potthoff der in lemberg für uns ist
immer mehr flüchtlinge philipp bekommen
natürlich im westen der ukraine an auch
kinder und du hast einige getroffen
erziehungs mehr affen
ganz genau mein pflege ziel der mann und
ich sind hier in den flüchtlingsheimen
unterwegs steht gerade vor einem und
hier kommen sehr viele frauen und kinder
und mit bild hielt also wie auch hier
ein bisschen zu helfen wir bringen den
kindern regelmäßig schokolade vorbei
einfach um sie ein bisschen auf
zuwanderung damit sie ein bisschen
ablehnen ablenkungen wir mit sie ein
bisschen freude haben nach dem was sie
erlebt haben und gestern haben wir
kinder auch gebeten dass sie für uns im
krieg machen so wie sie ihn erlebt haben
das sind kinder aus dem aushub aus also
kinder die im bombenhagel waren und
gehen von es waren natürlich ganz
rührend von diesen kindern zu hören und
auch zu sehen
was sie gespürt haben und die sagen auch
ganz offen auch jungs die vielleicht
sonst sagen nein ich habe keine angst
haben sagt doch ich hatte angst haben
wir immer wieder ein album gehört ein
geräusch sollen sie das gesagt und sie
wussten nicht was das war die inhalten
zuerst die ohren zugehalten haben
erklärt dass das nur dollar ist aber
irgendwann haben sie natürlich
verstanden dass das krieg ist es dass
flugzeuge sind die bomben und raketen
ob sie abwerten sie mussten sich in der
badewanne verstecken haben sich luft
scannern versteckt oder auch einfach wer
sich im gang im hausflur im treppenhaus
und das sind das sind kinder das
gründlich nie wieder vergessen werden
was ihnen passiert ist und das macht das
natürlich umso zynischer was russlands
außenminister rapperswil verbreitet hat
das ist kein krieg gegen die ukraine
gibt dass man sie nicht angegriffen hat
diese kinder wissen ganz genau was
interessiert ist und er das getan mit
welchen emotionen hast du diese bizarre
rede muss man sagen vom aussenminister
russlands von lavrov ebene wahrgenommen
es war ja genau so wie es zu erwarten
war
ich würde ihn eigentlich nur noch lügen
labeouf nennen
verbreitet das was das russische regime
schon seit jahren tut desinformation und
fake news auf die dreisteste
er ist natürlich ein absoluter gewusst
meister der desinformation der rhetorik
er schafft es immer wieder in sehr
eleganten wörtern diesen russischen
kriegsverbrechen zu verschleiern aber
diesmal gelingt es ihm eben nicht als
die ganze welt außer russland weiß was
hier passiert wenn die russische
bevölkerung wird zunehmend abgeschnitten
von freien informationen von
unabhängigen informationen ganz viele
russen glauben leider das was laufen
erzählt aber es ist gelogen es ist
falsch und es ist zynisch und dieser
macht also wie sein regime dafür
bestraft werden man hatte so viel
hoffnung heute in diese verhandlungen
und ja jetzt das wie weit ist der
frieden entfernt deiner meinung nach
geschrieben ist glaube ich noch sehr
weit weg selbst wenn es zu einer
waffenruhe kommen könnte wenn das
russische regime und wann in den
nächsten tagen und wochen versteht das
ist diesen krieg militärisch vielleicht
nicht gewinnen kann auch dann kann man
schwer frieden sprechen weil die ukraine
bleibt ja so bestehen wie sie ist mit
ein nachbar russland es regiert ist und
einem kriegsverbrecher wladimir putin
denn jederzeit erneut angreifen kann das
ist die große sorge der menschen was
passiert wenn das vorbei ist können wir
denn zurückkehren ihr in lembeck sind
zehntausende flüchtlinge die jeden acker
ankommen sind glaube ich mittlerweile
über zwei millionen menschen geflohen
und die würden wahnsinnig gerne in ihre
städte zurückkehren aber solange dieses
russland sofort besteht und gut hin
reagiert jeder zeit bereits einem
angriff wissen sie einfach nicht ob sie
das tun können philipp lemberg
seit tagen hin und her und du bist für
uns seit 14 tagen wenn wirklich fest
verankerten midlum bergen zwischen
philipp hauff aus lemberg vielen dank